في [__] رجال نقلت وكاله رويال فوستين عن
القوات الروسيه قولها انها دمرت منظومه
دفاعيه لمسلحين اوكرانيين في اتجاه ذا
بروسيا
ويوقفون اي محاولات لاختراق الدفاعات
مؤكدا استعدادا المقاتلين الروس لشني هجوم
في اي لحظه
ان السكان في جميع المدن والبلدات الواقعه
على الخطوط الاماميه لا يزالون في منازلها
تعملوا الادارات هو المدارس هو المستشفيات
وفيها بشكل كامل حسب قوله
مراسله منا سلام خضر اهلا بكما وابدا مع
كتابه
لروسيا من ان الجنود الروسي يحكمون
السيطره على محيط او حدود منطقه
زاباروجيه هل يؤكده الجانب الاوكراني على
الاقل حتى الان
مريم
الجنوبي هي المنطقه الوحيده بالفعل التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه من عموم
المدينه من عموم المقاطعه بالكامل
باستثناء تلك المنطقه هي في يد القوات
الاوكرانيه القوات الاوكرانيه تقول بان
هنالك معارك دائره عنوانها المدفعيه
راجمات الصواريخ بين همم بينها وبين
القوات الروسيه منذ الصباح والقوات
الاوكرانيه تقول بانها تكثف من قصفها مثلا
ل- اا منطقه من اليوتيوب وهي الواقعه في
ريف زبرج الجنوبي التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه الحديثه ايضا عن قصف اوكراني
متواصل للعديد من قرى وبلدات خطوط التماس
بين الطرفين والحديث تحديدا عن تركمان توك
ماك التي تقول القوات الاوكرانيه بانها
تمكنت بالفعل من قصفها على مدار فجر هذا
اليوم من خلال النهار وتحدثت عن قتلها
وجرها في صفوف القوات الروسيه وتحدثت ايضا
وهوما ينفي
المواليه للقوات الروسيه كما جاءت كما جاء
في الخبر قبل قليل تحدثت عن انسحاب بعض
الوحدات كما سمتها الوحدات العسكريه
الروسيه من بعض القرى من بعض البلدات على
الخطوط
المتقدمه الخطوط الاولى للجبهه وقالت بان
ذلك ناتج عن تكثيف الضربات الاوكرانيه لكن
بالمقابله قررت القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف
العديد من المناطق القرى البلدات الواقعه
ضمن سيطرتها وفي الحقيقه نحن نستمع من بين
الاخرى لهذا القصف حتى داخل المدينه
والكثير من المواقع التي قصفت يوم امس
وتحدث وصفتها القوات الاوكرانيه بانها
مناطق بنيه تحتيه وبناطق صناعيه صناعيه
يعني منعنع من الاقتراب منها لكن همم بسبب
الاجراءات العسكريه المشدده لكن نهايه
القصف ايضا متواصل القصف المتبادل في عديد
المقاطعه الجنوبيه نتحدث عن خير سون ميكو
لايف ديني برو واا مواقع اخرى